it's a pleasure to have you here
absolutely thanks for having me
uh
for the two people that are sitting in
the back that may not know who you are
you want to give a brief introduction
um I think it's probably more than that
uh I am a entrepreneur and investor I
run my family office now about half of
what we do is uh investing
um I would say about 50 of that
investing activity is in Bitcoin or kind
of crypto related startups uh the other
50 is either early stage technology
companies outside of crypto or in real
estate and then the other half the
family office is all operating
businesses that we own and operate
so which one of these takes the majority
of your focus now is it the investing
the analysis the media what is what's
the majority of the time spent on just
depends on the day
my wife and I like to joke all the time
that uh half my job is like doing the
things that are offensive uh and then
the other half is just putting out fires
and so one of the benefits of doing a
lot of different things is since it's
actually stimulating uh one of the
downsides to doing a lot of different
things is when shit's on fire it tends
to everything be on fire and so you got
a lot of work to do for sure I've seen
you be consistent for so many years in
the space and so I really want to get
your take on like this timeline where if
you can give us a comparison of crypto
2016 2017 to crypto today what are some
of the biggest differences that you're
seeing yeah so um I first heard about
Bitcoin in 2014 uh when I was working at
Facebook we just hired David Marcus from
PayPal
um and he was talking about Bitcoin and
integrating it into messenger and all
this stuff and I was just like you know
what is this I didn't nothing with it
and so I don't really have that much
context other than you know people
inside of Silicon Valley were talking
about it but it wasn't necessarily a
mainstream or widely accepted in 2016
2017 there was this massive bull market
uh Bitcoin went for about one thousand
dollars at the start of 2017 to 20 000
at the peak
um and it was the first time that really
it kind of broke through in the
mainstream media the media had
previously written about it but I think
they were starting to be like hey wait a
second all these idiots on the internet
actually are making money like what's
going on here right
um and what was interesting about it was
there was really kind of the first time
where it was Bitcoin and something else
and that was all the icos and
um the icos got so crazy that at one
point uh somebody sent me a link and
they're like hey there's a new project
they're raising some money if you're in
just put on this spreadsheet your name
the wallet address and how much eth
you're sending like I'm out right like
if that's how we're tracking stuff like
I'm out and I was pretty um
uh you know I think uh anti the Ico
movement less because I didn't think
that people weren't going to make money
but more so uh it was just very clear to
me The Regulators were going to step in
and that was unpopular at the time I
think now uh that's kind of more widely
held belief the biggest difference
though I see between then and now is
anyone in here think that all of crypto
is going to zero
probably not right we may debate what
assets going to be successful how big
will it be uh what type of people are
going to adopt it uh is it a financial
you know kind of speculation tool or is
it a technology that people actually use
in products all that stuff's Up For
Debate but in 2016 2017 like there was a
real point when Bitcoin dropped from 20
000 to 3 000. a lot of people were like
this could go to zero
um at the end of 2018 in December uh
myself and uh to my partners we issued a
kind of public bet and we said we'll
pick uh Bitcoin anyone on Wall Street
you can pick any other asset in the
world for a decade we'll put up a
million dollars and whoever's asset is
more successful uh against money
not one person took the bet and what
that said to me was wait a minute they
may publicly be not talking about this
they may be pretending like they're not
paying attention but they realize that
it's an asymmetric asset and so whenever
you have this asymmetry in a financial
instrument what ends up happening is you
can't count it out and that's what we
saw ultimately it came flying back from
30 from 3000 to the sixty nine thousand
dollars and so I think now people are
like okay this is going to stay it's
going to survive
um in uh the world the big questions now
are in the United States outside the
United States which ad sets are going to
be considered Securities which ones
aren't
um I don't necessarily have those
answers but I think that there's just
more nuanced conversation uh and there's
less of this binary will it survive or
will it not there's so many great topics
for us to touch on if we can just cover
what is your take on let's say Bitcoin
versus the altcoin market
and do you feel like anything has
changed in your perspectives in the past
three four years on that or do you still
feel like there's a clear separation
between those assets
yeah so I mean you can break it down uh
by a bunch of different perspectives so
first start with uh the technology
itself I believe that Bitcoin is the
only truly decentralized technology now
everyone in this industry is very
focused on the word decentralized it's
almost become like this marketing term
right but you have to remember
decentralization has trade-offs it's not
good or bad if Amazon was decentralized
that would be horrible for their
business right Amazon's all about
efficiency and being able to quickly
deliver something it still amazes me I
can press a button on my phone so they
can show up you know literally hours
later and so Bitcoin being decentralized
is because it's specifically optimizing
for security censorship resistance Etc
there's many other Technologies uh that
people are building where they're
basically trying to use the idea of
decentralization but still capitalize uh
on efficiency speed low cost Etc now
Bitcoin believes that you can do that on
other layers so layer two layer three
some of these other Technologies came
out and they said they were going to do
it on the layer one so I think that
that's probably one of the biggest
differences is that Bitcoin is actually
decentralized it uh the Creator is
unknown
um you know I saw somebody joking on
Twitter yesterday they're like the SEC
is going to send a cease and desist to
the creator of Bitcoin but they can't
find them
again haha right got it but like it's
highlighting this point of
um it is definitely different right the
second is on the regulatory front uh it
appears that the SEC cftc here in the
United States but also regulatory bodies
around uh the world have all said
Bitcoin is not a security everything
else is now whether that actually ends
up being the final verdict or not uh
there's a number of companies binance
coinbase and others that are going to go
and and kind of have their day in court
I don't know right and I think that it's
always been this like unknown risk
um the community identified it early and
they've been debating it for years at
some point we're going to get that
answer maybe it's next year maybe it's
10 years from now but at some point
we'll find that out but I do think that
Bitcoin is kind of passed all those
filters on the regulatory front
the third thing is uh currently Bitcoin
has really been the only asset where
institutional investors have warmed up
to allocating to it there's been a
couple I think publicly announced uh
institutions that have also bought uh
ether or ethereum but those are pretty
few and far between and then pretty much
almost everything else has been ignored
by the institutional world
some people will argue oh that's because
they're newer and give it a couple years
and institutions will go buy that stuff
too some people argue no it's because
it's not actually worth anything and you
know they're going to completely ignore
it again I I don't know what'll happen
there but I do know that Bitcoin has
kind of crossed over and now is seen as
one of these institutional uh assets and
you see that not only with uh public
companies like microstrategy and others
putting it on their balance sheet Tesla
Etc but you also see a lot of large
Financial organizations building
Technologies around this I mean Fidelity
Investments is a massive you know
company with over a trillion dollars of
assets they have a whole dedicated team
to building all of this stuff and
building Technologies and custody and
try to help people get onboarded Etc and
then what you see is uh I don't think
we've ever heard a major macro Trader
Stanley drucken Miller Paul Tudor Jones
Bill Miller Etc talk about anything
other than Bitcoin and again does that
mean that they don't hold the other
stuff maybe does it mean that they don't
yet feel comfortable talking about it
does it mean that maybe they're worried
about regulatory risk I'm not sure but
what it it does say to me is again
Bitcoin seems to kind of passed over
this threshold and be in kind of a
different category to some degree so
when I look at those three things I say
to myself okay well those are like
positives for Bitcoin what's the
downside argument and it depends on who
you're talking to if I go and I talk to
somebody on Wall Street who runs a hedge
fund or a big family office many of them
think that Bitcoin is the single most
risky thing that they could invest in
right they don't even look at the rest
of the market but they just look at
Bitcoin like okay I got my stocks my
bonds maybe some Commodities real estate
whatever
this Bitcoin thing is crazy I'm gonna
put half a percent and so if you then go
talk to like a 22 year old you know
crypto Degen they're like dude you hold
Bitcoin like Bitcoin is by far the like
Boomer coin right it's like the it's
like the least risky thing why are you
buying that and so I've for years now
said like that's actually where I want
to sit I want to hold the asset that is
riskiest to the most conservative people
and I want to hold the asset that is
safest to the riskiest people so it kind
of sits right there in the middle now
what that means is yes if you're looking
for the absolute uh Highest Potential
return and you don't care about risk
then sure go speculate on you know
whatever latest coin is whatever I just
think that that's no different than
going and buying penny stocks or you
know doing anything else in financial
markets if you're instead looking at it
from a risk adjusted standpoint I think
that Bitcoin probably provides one of
the best opportunities uh across all
financial markets and so when you look
at bitcoin's performance compared to
stocks or other assets it's down right
now from the all-time high and there's a
lot of people on Wall Street who
appoints I see you idiots I told you
if we go back to the start of the
pandemic though Bitcoin is up over 300
percent and so this argument that
Bitcoin was going to serve as this
inflation hedge right
plenty of people in the kind of Bitcoin
and crypto World said it but Paul Tudor
Jones daily Draco Miller Etc said it as
well it seems to have worked and so when
you see that you're like okay well the
next time that we start to see inflation
Rising is the Playbook learned right and
if that's the case instead of there
being tens of billions of dollars
allocated as there was in 2020 2021 and
into 2022. next time is it hundreds of
billions of dollars again you know maybe
it's just we're all biased and we kind
of look at it through that lens
um but I do tend to think that uh what
we have seen is Bitcoin in any moments
of cracks in the Legacy Financial system
seems to serve as a flight to safety and
so whether it's a banking crisis
inflation debt default Etc
becomes pretty interesting when you're
like hey man there's not a lot of those
people holding that asset yet but if
they start to you know things change
so
in terms of the in terms of Bitcoin
being a safe haven when everyone's
trying to kind of flow out of other
currencies do you do you see it as a
potential threat to the US dollar before
I ask this next question I don't think
so um at least in the short to medium
term if you think about it how many
people here have 100 of their net worth
in Bitcoin
nobody nobody right no nobody does right
okay how many of you here spend more
than 50 of the currency that you spend
is in Bitcoin to buy things nobody right
and so it's no different than gold or
real estate or even stock portfolios in
that sense people are looking at this as
an allocation from an investment
standpoint and they're holding it every
single investment asset is a speculative
tool and so maybe we can talk about a
little bit is like most of the things
that you've been taught about investing
are wrong right and when I say that it
really really upsets kind of the Legacy
world but it's true so first of all
they're like oh that's just for
speculation Warren Buffett speculates
with hundreds of billions of dollars a
year that dude's a gambler
right you can dress it up you can put
the suit and tie on you can read the you
know uh annual reports you can hold your
whole you know uh Carnival out in Omaha
but at the end of the day you're a
gambler that's what investing is you're
taking risks and so if you look at that
Bitcoin is no different than any of
these other assets the second thing is
that Bitcoin is the only truth teller in
the market and what I mean by that is
it's the most free market that we have
there's definitely things that are wrong
with it and I wish that it could be even
Freer than it is but if you look at the
way Bitcoin performed in terms of
inflation
Bitcoin ran up before inflation hit so
one of the misconceptions in investing
is when inflation was high Bitcoin was
falling that must mean Bitcoin is not a
good inflation hedge but what people
forget is that markets are
forward-looking
if I know that inflation is coming I
believe inflation is coming I don't wait
for inflation to come and then move my
assets I move the Assets in anticipation
of the event and so in 2020 when
everyone said High inflation is coming
they're printing trillions of dollars
they've dropped the interest rate people
moved assets Bitcoin went from ten
thousand to sixty thousand dollars High
inflation hit Bitcoin stayed high for a
while but in November of 21 when all of
a sudden the Federal Reserve started to
say we are going to bring markets down
we are going to uh increase interest
rates Bitcoin fell
and everyone's like see it failed but no
actually Bitcoin told you the truth
Bitcoin LED markets and said we are
going to go down in price and soar all
these other markets and then you saw
stocks real estate everything else kind
of followed and so what that ultimately
leads to is that the efficient market
hypothesis which majority of investors
base their investment decisions on
majority of the mainstream media based
their perspective of financial markets
on and I would even argue majority of
the market itself is based on this idea
of the efficient market hypothesis which
basically says everyone given the same
information has the same knowledge and
therefore perfectly priced into an asset
that's like the dumbest thing in the
world
right like literally just think about
this for a second we have an entire
multi-trillion dollar Financial system
that is built on a lie and the reason
why I say that is because how many
people in here know that the Bitcoin
having exists
right okay how many people in here know
when it is next
some people how many people in here
think that the Bitcoin having is bullish
and will lead to a higher price
okay how many people in here think that
the Bitcoin having is going to lead to a
lower price
couple hands now why is that interesting
we all have the same information we know
that the having exists we know when it
is but we have a different perspective
on what's going to happen so if I tell
you I can in advance tell you next
quarter apple is going to make a hundred
billion dollars in profit
some of you will be like oh my God I'm
gonna go buy Apple stock because that's
going to be this great performance some
of you will take that same piece of
information and you will say to yourself
well I thought they were gonna make 120
billion so they're gonna actually miss
and therefore I should short the stock
because I think it's going to go down
the efficient market hypothesis is not
real and the reason why that's important
is because the only thing that is real
is the market there is no efficient
market is an inefficient Market of
people who come together who Express a
view and they trade they take positions
and so Bitcoin having this free market
if Bitcoin goes down 50 in a day there's
no circuit breaker there's no stopping
it no one steps in and says hey let's
halt trading for 15 minutes
right I joke with people like that's
little boy stuff Wall Street needs those
guard rails this is a free market and so
if you then look at it and you say hey
if you then look at it and say
they're sleeping right now
why are why are the assets not Trading
why are stocks not trading right now the
U.S stock market has closed more hours a
year than it is open
why
it's because Americans have created a
system that works for Americans
but there's a whole Global base of
people who want to participate in the
capital markets
and guess what 86 of all trading of
Bitcoin happens outside the United
States
we're just a small fraction of the
percent of people who participate in
this and so when Americans are sleeping
and other people are awake around the
world they can't participate why is that
well maybe America has to be a little
bit more humble and say hey we're
playing a global game now 24 7 365 this
thing trades in a free market and so you
can imagine well what would happen if
the stock market
that happened they would never let it
occur right because there's it's all
about control it's all about trying to
push all this trading into a short
period of time and so it goes back to
this idea that Bitcoin is the free
market and what we have seen over and
over and over again over the last couple
years is that everything else is a lie
Bitcoin is the only truth teller in
financial markets CPI data people in
here will think it's a lot some people
will believe it people will look at
asset prices they'll say that it's a lie
but what we do know is that Bitcoin
continues to trade 24 7 365 with
hundreds of millions of people around
the world and it seems to be able to
tell us what is coming down the pike in
all of these other financial markets and
I think it's worth at least watching it
I mean you got to buy it I mean you got
to trade it but if you watch it it will
tell you what's happening better than
almost any other asset
as as accurate
as accurate as Bitcoin is it's also
relatively new so it may be hard to kind
of really pinpoint what is the thing
that makes it move and I just posed the
question to Glenn and Michaela while
they were up here and we were mentioning
how liquidity really drives the market
what do you feel like are those driving
forces that either push the
cryptocurrency market to start seeing a
lot of money coming in or money going
out so I have to admit I'm not that
smart and so whenever I look at price I
just look at it as a function of supply
and demand if more people want to buy
then sell the price goes up right if
more people want to sell them buy the
price goes down and so the reason why I
say that is I think a lot of people
across financial markets even you know I
spent a lot of time with some of the
people who run some of the largest hedge
funds in the world Etc
it's just it's easy to get things
complicated and so if you actually look
at some of the best investors in the
world what they have figured out is can
you tell it to me in two simple
sentences
right how many of you in here make
investment decisions and could literally
say to somebody else I'm doing this
because you get two sentences no big
words
that's it right in 2020 I came out and
you know I had been pretty bullish on
bitcoin before I was doing a whole bunch
of different investing across different
markets and it was like
hitting me over the head in terms of how
obvious they are going to drop interest
rates they're going to print money and
at the same time there's going to be a
supply shock in terms of the having and
so it was they're basically going to
push liquidity in the market and they're
going to cut Supply it's going to be
rocket fuel for Bitcoin and when I first
started saying it people were like oh
this is just like another you know you
think it's going to go up you think it's
good now whatever
but the reason why it was so powerful to
me is like that was the simplest
explanation I could think of right and
so if you go and you look today it's
like what drives the price it's
literally demand because Bitcoin
specifically is a very unique asset how
many people in here know how many
Bitcoin there's ever going to be
right how many people in here know how
many Bitcoin come into the market every
day
you can see it right and so if you know
what Supply is going to be then you only
have to understand what demand is doing
and is demand increasing or decreasing
so it actually people in this market
have an advantage over traditional
investors right if you trade stock how
many of you have woken up one day and
you're like [__] these guys just issued
a bunch more Equity right these guys
just did this these guys are buying back
stock right like you have to worry about
the supply side and you don't know what
they're going to do they don't Telegraph
it all the time and so that ends up
being this really interesting thing of
like the price is ultimately driven by
increases or decreases in demand
the hard part is it's 24 7 365 Global
investor base like it's not just what do
people in the United States think and so
if you look at an event like uh turkey
or Argentina there's all these currency
crises there's High inflation there's
all these issues that they're dealing
with those people are running to Dollars
Bitcoin anything to get out of their
local currency
but they're still small markets so it's
not as simple of an analysis of like
Argentina has 90 inflation they all want
Bitcoin
maybe and so really what I think ends up
happening I know a lot of you guys in
here are Traders I kind of just opt out
of the game I just say look I'm actually
not smart enough to know what is the
intraday or you know intra week intra
month movements of these assets I simply
want to buy this asset over time hold it
and literally give it to my grandkids
which is like antithetical to everything
a Trader believes but the reason why I
think of that is you have to understand
what game you're playing and if you can
trade more power to you Bitcoin super
volatile that's why a lot of the market
making firms Etc all want to trade it
and so therefore you're able to actually
go and make a profit if you're not good
at Trading
next best thing is just to hold the
asset for a really long time and so in
some way I've kind of given up on trying
to understand price and just said let me
play a different game
now what gives you the confidence to
know or what gives you the confidence to
assume that Bitcoin Will Survive the
test of time uh you know kind of looking
at the regulatory environment looking at
how much
how many attacks there are in the crypto
space and I genuinely feel like the
attacks on some of the centralized
institutions now are because they can't
go after Bitcoin if you can't go after
Bitcoin let's go after literally
everybody else and see what sticks so
because of all of these attacks what
gives you the confidence to know that's
going to be here so there's I think two
different components of this right the
first is Bitcoin is software it's no
different than iOS running on your phone
or any other software program that you
use if you understand what software is
it is words written in a database
right boil it down to like its most
fundamental thing it's words written in
a database that then is run by all these
computers around the world one big
difference is that apple or Amazon or
Facebook doesn't control that database
it's instead this decentralized network
so Bitcoin will survive if literally
aliens come tomorrow and kill everyone
except for one person and they have
Bitcoin running on their computer
Bitcoin survives right so from a
technical standpoint now if there's only
one person left in the world bitcoin's
probably not that valuable right and so
then there's the question about like
what about the resilience of price or
the value of the asset I do believe that
Bitcoin derives a lot of value from
being the strongest computer network in
the world many of you probably heard me
say this before one of the critiques of
Bitcoin specifically is this idea that
uh Bitcoin is not backed by anything
right put aside the ridiculous arguments
of like well neither is the dollar but
ask yourself what is the single most
valuable commodity in the world today
it's not oil it's not you know corn it's
not wheat it's not any of that stuff
it's computing power
computing power is the single most
valuable commodity in the world that's
why things like Amazon's AWS trade at
such crazy multiples if they were a
separate company is because ultimately
they're no different than Standard Oil a
hundred years ago being in control of
the flow of oil
Amazon controls the flow of computing
power Google controls the flow of
computing power it's the single most
valuable commodity in the world so
bitcoin's actually backed by the
strongest computer network in the world
which means that it is backed by the
most valuable commodity in the world and
so if you look at that you say it's
worth something but the market has to
decide what that value is now what we do
know is that right now let's say that
there's 150 million people who have
raised their hand and said hey I'm going
to participate in this market
it ain't billion people
right and so what ends up happening is
that more and more people continue to
come into the market they continue to
learn about the asset as they do that
price will continue to grind slowly up
as a simple function of supply and
demand and so in some weird way Bitcoins
uh survival from a technology standpoint
is in the decentralization but the
resilience of value ends up being in
this idea that the fixed Supply only has
to have increasing demand over time in
order for the price to continue to grow
and so when you see that that's why I
look at it no different than I look at
real estate the some of the wealthiest
people in the world I think it's
um if I remember correctly 70 or 80 of
all millionaires in the United States
did it in real estate
why because real estate was built for
dummies
buy something
and hold it
right and when you think about that
you're like wait what are you talking
about all you're doing is you're
converting Dollars into a hard asset and
then you're just letting them devalue
the dollar and as they devalue the
dollar somebody else shows up and they
need more dollars to buy that asset from
you in the future
and so at the end of the day yeah you're
making the investment decision but
really all you're doing is you're
allowing the structure of the market to
enrich you
and so people got really mad during the
pandemic when I said literally the
number one thing that we can do for
financial uh kind of uh excellence in
Financial Health in the United States is
just teach people invest
don't don't finish the sentence just
invest
if you buy anything that most people
would consider to be low risk you likely
will do well over the lifetime uh that
you live simply because they are forced
to devalue the dollar
and so if you buy the S P 500 and you
forget about it and come back 30 years
later you're rich
it's that simple if you buy real estate
forget about it come back you're
probably Rich same thing with Bitcoin
same thing with a lot of these assets
and so there's a study that Fidelity did
this maybe like 15 years ago now uh
they've actually uh reportedly deleted
it from the internet which I find
interesting
they studied all of the accounts and
they were looking for what are the
correlations between the best performing
accounts you know what the answer was
people who forgot their passwords or
died
right which is like insane right but
like think about it if you just bought a
basket of stocks and left it for 20
years and came back probably gonna be
higher right and that's what the whole
idea the indexes Etc are and so if you
think about this uh from uh the sense of
Bitcoin I do tend to think that uh
allowing the US dollar to just continue
to be devalued like they're telling you
that is their system and so maybe it's
just I'm not smart enough to do it but
if you can just do that one thing
you're gonna be okay
I heard it you guys heard it less is
more
now if we're going to talk about uh you
did mention some of the global issues
like Argentina and like turkey
over the years that you've been studying
Bitcoin have you seen Bitcoin as a
viable solution to some of those
currency devaluations or maybe what's
happening in Venezuela or has it just
not gotten the adoption that people
thought it would and just fell flat on
his face how many people in here were
born in another country or live in
another country right now right anybody
okay
if you go and you talk to the people in
those countries and you ask them the
currency fails what do you want majority
of people will say US dollars
in the US we're like oh this dog [__]
currency right
because we're all idiot like like the
American Experience is so insane to
anyone outside of the United States
right but we're like oh this stupid
currency but if you think somebody in
Argentina they're like are you guys
kidding me you have the dollar and so I
do think that most people in those
countries that's what they want they
want dollars right they want safety they
want the full faith and credit of the
United States government now what ends
up happening is in some countries like
take a Venezuela uh and you talk to
people on the ground there they're like
look it's dangerous to try to get
dollars right if I go and I put the
dollars in the bank account how do I
know tomorrow doesn't get confiscated if
I go and I try to get it in the black
market sometimes I have to do things
that are dangerous in terms of literally
physically getting the dollars and so
then if I get the dollars I gotta hold
the dollar so what if somebody comes to
my house and takes the dollars from me
and so in those uh situations then maybe
people say you know what actually
Bitcoin may be a better thing and so
back in I think it was 2019 I went on
National Television I said the single
greatest thing that the United States
could do to continue to uh proliferate
the United States dollar around the
world is to digitize it
because guess what happens if I'm
sitting in Venezuela and it's dangerous
to get dollars or any other fiat
currency in physical form
I go on the internet and I actually
don't want Bitcoin at first I want
dollars and if there's a digital dollar
there and I can just click some buttons
and get dollar exposure and I don't have
to worry about it sitting at a local
bank I'm probably gonna do that
but my big concern at the time was China
was creating a digital currency and so
what happens if I go on the internet
there's no digital dollar but there's a
digital Juan or a digital Yen or a
digital Euro or some other currency
well [__] it that sounds better than you
know get my money taken from me so I'll
just buy that and so what I think is
happening now is the United States
actually has a national security issue
on hand in that if we want to continue
to get dollars into people's hands in
the digital world we have to create
digital dollars there's obviously stable
coins and some people are getting those
but the United States government is
going to have to do that now where does
Bitcoin come into this there's a lot of
people who just say you know what screw
it just like here in the United States I
actually think that the dollar is going
to be devalued or whatever so I'm just
going to buy Bitcoin instead and so what
you see in these countries is that there
is a drastic uptick the reason why the
number 86 percent of all Bitcoin is
traded outside the United States is
interesting to me I worked at Facebook
in 2013 or uh 2014 2015. when I left in
2015 guess how many users on Facebook's
platform was outside the United States
about 86 percent
and so I don't yet know and I'm trying
to understand is that because the way
these networks grow after about 10 years
Facebook was started in 2004 right we're
14 years into Bitcoin or so is that kind
of the percentage breakdown is about 14
15 is in the U.S 85 or so is outside the
U.S or is it just something that happens
to Overlay and look nice right I'm not
sure yet but what I do know is that if
85 or so percent is outside the United
States those people may be buying it
because they think they're gambling they
may be buying it because their currency
is failing they may be buying it because
they think that their government's going
to confiscate their assets or they
simply may be buying it because their
friend told them to
but it doesn't matter
if they continue to have demand a fixed
Supply asset
it'll continue to grind up over time
wow
guys this is so many gems so so many
gems I think the biggest takeaway is
this idea because in traditional assets
you have to think about both sides of
the coin how much Supply is there how
much exists out there gold or diamonds
or whatever it is and the demand side
which is how many people want it
this is would you say this is the only
asset that really only has that one side
Dynamic not that they can't make more
real estate
but they they you know you go to Dubai
for example and they really do create
more real estate or Elon suggests that
we can find gold on an asteroid
somewhere when it comes to bitcoin is it
truly the only scarce asset
I think that it is the only provably
scarce asset at the moment now sure
maybe somebody figures out a way to you
know find all of the gold deposits in
the earth and they can prove that
they'll never be more gold or whatever
um but I do think it's the only provably
uh scarce asset the reason why scarcity
is so interesting is because it is
scarcing that there is 21 million
Bitcoin but if you then look at how many
satoshi's right there's 100 million
satoshi's or SATs and uh every Bitcoin
Etc is it's an accessible yet scarce
asset which means that you can go and
you can buy something with one dollar
right I always uh laugh people like yeah
you know if you buy a high-rise towers
in Manhattan uh they're not making more
of those okay who here's doing that
right like you need a lot of money you
need like it it's not accessible asset
and so I do think that there is this
element of scarcity that plays out
um but but I also think that Bitcoin
specifically uh a lot of people don't
put value on the brand
bitcoin's probably one of the most
valuable brands in the world
right people know Apple everywhere you
can go anywhere in the world people know
Apple
most countries people know Amazon
most countries people know Google
Bitcoin is known globally and they did
it without a board of directors without
an executive team without a marketing
budget Etc and the reason is because how
many people in here own Bitcoin
you all are employees of Bitcoin
you're holding Bitcoin you're
contributing to the network by holding
the asset
but guess what out of the people who
just raise your hand how many of you
told your friend about Bitcoin
you're part of the marketing team
right
so
[Applause]
it's this weird thing of like I think
when people first find Bitcoin like uh
what's the joke uh you don't need to ask
people if they do CrossFit they'll tell
you right same thing about Bitcoin is
like you don't need to ask people if
they own Bitcoin they'll tell you
um but I've gone through this like weird
kind of progression where when I first
heard about it I was like oh my God I
have to tell everyone
and now I'm just like all right but you
know like there's enough people there's
enough whatever but but I do think that
there's this element of uh when you
really study this asset the brand the
the word of mouth all these things I
always joke that you could take Warren
Buffett's investing principle I'm a huge
Warren Buffett fan minus his views on
bitcoin and crypto but I'm a huge Warren
Buffett fan in the sense of I think that
he took Timeless investing principles
and he basically was the first Finance
influencer
right think of what Warren Buffett does
he does interviews rarely he has a
conference and he puts out blog posts
once a year that everyone goes crazy
over he just calls him an annual report
but like Warren Buffett's a [__]
influencer right just for Boomers
and if Warren Buffett was 25 today he'd
have a Twitter account a tick tock a
podcast a sub stack like all this [__]
right
so if you think of it from that he just
popularized these ideas that he learned
from someone else but his entire
investing philosophy basically is find
great assets and hold them forever
and then find things that have great
Word of Mouth brand all these things
Bitcoin fits every single thing that he
talks about except for cash flow right
he's very big on cash flow the
difference is he looks at it as uh the
Bitcoin holder has no cash flow
true
but the Bitcoin network if we were to
centralize it and say okay now all of
that mining Revenue all those
transaction fees are going to get booked
under one single p l
and Bitcoin is pretty [__] valuable
right a lot of cash flow in there and so
what ends up happening is that you have
to look for assets or at least my my
view is that you have to look for assets
that check the boxes of all these
Timeless investing principles they are
Timeless for a reason
but if you can find new assets that fit
the old kind of framework early then
you're able to benefit as more and more
of the world understands them no
different than if you're the guy or girl
who finds the stock that you think is
going up and no one else knows about it
and then everyone on Wall Street figures
it out later the price goes up same
thing here and I think that Bitcoin kind
of fits into that mold
awesome
I heard you talk many years ago I think
it was CNBC with Andrew Ross Sorkin
you're basically you I think at the time
you were a Bitcoin maximalist because I
think that you were one of the largest
proponents for Bitcoin is that fair to
say I think you were one of the biggest
faces of Bitcoin for many years yeah
CNBC uh they let me go on one time and
that probably was the mistake
um because uh most people go on there
and they have like their talking points
and you know they're just like they're
like brag about whatever they're doing
but with like Bitcoin I got nothing to
do with Bitcoin like I don't I matter
zero to bitcoin every single person in
this room you met her zero to Bitcoin in
the grand scheme of things right
um but I kind of was just like [__] it
so they were all you know [__] on it
and Kevin O'Leary was screaming at me or
whatever and
okay right and so I grew up with four
brothers like we just talk [__] so I
just talk [__] back
it was like uh it was like a knee-jerk
reaction like you're talking [__] out of
college fire back
um and so in some way it was like maybe
I was like the most believable [__]
poster from Twitter that they were like
all right like maybe he's not gonna say
too crazy of things
um but what I did learn through all of
that was anyone remember what Kevin
O'Leary was saying at the time
he hated it hated it there was a bunch
of people now that are in crypto that
hated it
he said it would never work he literally
I mean dead serious right before I went
on uh they were like oh by the way Kevin
O'Leary's gonna be on I was like oh cool
like I've seen Shark Tank and I hear him
say this is all crypto garbage I was
like oh [__] right
and so if you think about it uh he
changed his mind
the smartest best people in the world
changed their mind Paul Tudor Jones the
only dragon they all changed their mind
about it right Kevin O'Leary did as well
even some of the people on CNBC Joe
Kernan right he used to just be like I
don't know what this thing is and then
he started like talking about Bitcoin
and the bitcoiners if there's one thing
bitcoiners are good at doing they'll gas
up anyone who's into Bitcoin right they
had memes they had Joe with the laser
eyes like they were like Joe welcome
we've been waiting for you right Elon
same thing Elon bought Bitcoin Elon you
know everyone looked welcome we've been
waiting for you
um and so I think that that is one of
the big things is like the mainstream
media now is uh they may still be
critical of it they may still be maybe
cautiously optimistic some of them
um but they're talking about it and so
if we look across Society like actually
controversy is drives a ton of uh
marketing and that's kind of what
Bitcoin has on these mainstream media is
that they ultimately are uh debating it
which normalizes it and so I was joking
with somebody yesterday
how many people in here have a kid who
is 13 years old or younger
all right your kid doesn't know a world
without Bitcoin
right
I have a young daughter she doesn't know
[__] about the world without mobile
phones like that kid navigates the phone
better than me right and so when you
think about it from that perspective
you're like wait a second think about
this timeline gold is 5 000 years old
I can't even comprehend 5 000 years I
couldn't name like three people that
lived five thousand years ago it's just
been here forever
there's no difference between 5 000 and
literally dinosaurs right like it's just
like forever
Fiat has been around for 50 years
1971 to now right 53 years whatever it
is
Bitcoin has been around for 14.
in the grand scheme of things of human
history Fiat and Bitcoin are the same
age
right it's basically no difference it's
just that we happen to have been born
many of us before that happened or I'm
sorry after that happened
and so when you think of it from that
perspective over time a bunch of people
are going to grow up and they're just
going to be like yeah duh Bitcoin
right like it's not going to be new to
them it's not going to be different it's
not going to be shiny it's just going to
be a thing that's always been around
and the lie that humans have is like you
ever hear about something and you just
think it's been around forever
like elevators right people are just
like yeah they had elevators like
definitely back in like Egyptian times
for sure
right you're like wait a minute that
shit's only 100 years old
like my great great grandfather didn't
have a [__] elevator like what
that must have been a lot of stairs so
like you think about this stuff and
you're just like if it's around now it
must have been here forever but that's
not actually what occurs and so I do
think that the normalization will end up
being kind of a Tailwind over time
um because people will just say uh oh my
parents or my grandparents or whatever
uh they were into it so of course I'm
going to be as well that would have been
a perfect place to end but I have to ask
you one last question which is uh could
you give us probably the craziest
experience that you've been able to have
being in the crypto world like whether
it's a room that you've got to be in a
place you've got to go speak what is
what is something that stood out to you
just being involved in crypto
there's a lot I can't say uh that I
really wish I could
um
maybe a fun one
um in New York in 2018
uh in August of 2018 I wrote a piece
Bitcoin had fallen from 20 000 to like 6
500 and it was kind of going sideways
and again I'm not a Trader price you
know I'm as stupid as they come but
I talked to a lot of people who I
thought were smart and they were like
hey this thing's Gonna Keep Falling uh
it's probably going to fall to three
thousand dollars and I was like well you
guys are all smart you're all saying the
same thing like I guess that's what's
going to happen and so I wrote a piece
publicly and I was like Bitcoin probably
goes to 3 000 before 10 000 but like
they said it not me so if it doesn't
happen like not my fault right
um and so that's what happened
and when it dropped uh I
um I got a LinkedIn like connection
request
from a guy who worked at a sovereign
wealth fund and I was like scammer right
for sure like no way this is real but I
looked I Googled his name there was a
person by that name whatever I talked to
one of my partners he was like well if
that guy really works there we should
definitely meet with him so I like
messaged back but kind of like
cryptically you know like uh Hey
like you know put the bait see what he
does long story short is he comes to New
York uh and we meet with them and uh we
had a whole team we put together like a
25 page you know white paper explaining
what Bitcoin was probably all the stuff
we could do in a portfolio all this you
know all like the smart people [__]
whatever
and we got in the meeting and towards
the end he asked me okay so what do you
want from me
and I just stone-faced him and hit him
with 1.2 billion dollars so I can go buy
one percent of the Bitcoin Network and
your country will be Rich Forever
and he looked back at me and he was like
that's interesting
[Music]
[Laughter]
I can't share what a country it is but
uh it's I mean it's one that people
would expect there's only so many of
them that have enough that could put one
billion dollars in and not really care
um and what was funny though was this
was a younger guy he was focused on like
super Innovative asymmetric type
opportunities like this fit what he was
looking for he went back and uh this
specific place has a couple of different
tiers to their investment committee and
he went to the first meeting he got like
three minutes into the pitch supposedly
and they were just like dude get out of
here
so he had to call me back and like I
think it's a great idea but like yeah
that's going to be a no-go for us and so
every once in a while I send him updates
on the price
and so when it kind of Hit the 10x Mark
I was like hey man they 20x Mark I was
like hey man
I'm waiting now it's back down he's
gonna be like hey man
ladies and Gentlemen please give a round
of applause to Anthony popliano
thank you